So you might say,
well,
what happens when you,
when you feel one way and you say
something else,
I mean you're all in,
you're all perfectly,
it's the middle year with that
experience.
In fact,
my experience with people has been that,
and this is another issue with
instrumental use of language.
You know,
you say,
well what are you using your language
for?
Well,
have to get what you want,
but that can be consciously manipulated.
Then maybe we'll say,
well that's what the psychopath is like
except the psychopath is not only
consciously manipulative,
he's also unconsciously manipulative
because he's been practicing it for like
three decades.
So all the little machines in his head
or deceptive too,
and they run on automatic.
So he'll just lie just to see if he can
pull one over on you because that
demonstrates that not only is he smarter
than you,
but that you deserve to be victimized
because you're such an idiot.
So,
but people use instrumental language
like that.
Not only consciously to get what they
want,
but you know,
it's something that we definitely think
of is characteristic for example of
teenagers.
Right?
I mean,
there isn't a teen movie that's be made
in the last 50 years.
I don't think.
It doesn't deal with the negative
consequences of using instrumental
language.
Right.
Basically the team has put in some
position where they're being pulled,
pulled by maybe various social forces,
different friendship groups or,
or there's a,
um,
but there was a
contradictory relationship between what
their friends want and their parents
want or what their friends want and
there's school wants or what they want
and their friends want or what the
school wants.
So all of these things are pulling and
pushing in different directions and the
directions are essentially in some,
in some sense the directions or moral
because they're all about what to do.
And the,
the plot of the movie is how the
teenager,
it's usually a Rogerian plot.
It's usually about how the teenager
comes to more to fuller self
realization.
Right.
And that they're able to,
that they're able to stave off the,
the temptations that are posed sometimes
by the authorities,
so they don't become too obedient and
sometimes by their peers so that they
don't become only a reflection of peer
pressure.
Question.
I was just going to say,
wouldn't care.
Absolutely.
Peer pressure,
peer peer pressure is absolutely that.
And so if you're using language to fit
in,
well that's also instrumental use of
language and for,
and for Rogers,
that would be one of the sources of
pathology.
Now
it's very much worth taking this
seriously.
So
here's an example that I thought about a
lot.
What do you do if you're at work and
someone tells you to do something that
you don't want to do?
And I don't mean that,
forget,
assume you're disciplined,
you know,
assume that you're not just lazy and
worthless.
And that's why you don't want to do it.
And you want to ask yourself that first,
right?
Because maybe you're just being lazy and
worthless and you should pull yourself
together and do the thing you know.
So,
but failing that,
let's say that you're being asked to do
something that you're finding,
you're having a very difficult time to
get motivated to do.
So that'd be one clue.
And that it's also making you uneasy.
So you're waking up in the middle of the
night and you're being anxious and it's
running through your mind.
And
what should you do?
Well,
it's your job.
Someone who is in the hierarchy above
you is telling you to do it.
Maybe you should just do it.
Well then you might ask yourself,
well,
why can't you just go ahead and do it?
You know,
you might say,
well,
maybe it's because I criminal and you're
afraid of getting caught,
but let's forget about that for a
minute.
Let's assume that the probability,
maybe it's a low level moral
transgression,
it's not precisely illegal.
And even so the probability that you're
going to get caught is very low.
Why would it bother you and should you
take that seriously?
Now Rogers would claim that the reason
it would bother you is because it would
make the structure of yourself system
inconsistent.
So
imagine you're trying to organize a
group of people to do some tasks.
You know,
like maybe they were in a row and you
have to fill it in a hole in the road.
And so you have to put people in a row
and you've,
you handed rocks down the line.
You know,
if you got one person in there who is
trying to put rocks,
make the rocks go the other way or
dropping them or something like that,
well then obviously the entire structure
is not going to function properly.
And it's because there's an internally
to consistency in 10 you know,
it's a fundamental presupposition of,
of,
of logic.
It's maybe the most fundamental
principle of communication that a thing
can't be itself and something else at
the same time.
That's the principle of
noncontradiction.
Right.
And so the hypothesis here would be that
you have to follow the principle of
noncontradiction with regards to the
organization of your own self.
The self would be,
Roger's thinks about that as an are a
differentiated field,
subfield of the phenomenal field.
Right?
So you're always experiencing things and
part of what you've experienced is that
you at the center of that and that's the
self as far as Roger's is concerned.
And the proposition would be you have to
organize the self in a non contradictory
manner or well or what well or you feel
negative emotion.
Now he would think about that as anxiety
general.
Yes we can start the narrative around,
well that might work.
You know,
I mean that's a very good and
complicated question because what you're
asking is,
well why,
why can't you rationalize effectively?
That's really,
well
that's a postmodern theory I would say
in some sense because the postmodern
like to claim that there's nothing
outside of the text.
Right?
And then things in some sense are
infinitely malleable and that the
malleability comes as a consequence of
the different narratives that you like
might weave.
But Rogers would point out that,
well the first thing he pointed out is
that stupid,
which it is.
I mean there's all sorts of things that
are characteristics of your
characteristic,
of your experience that haven't gone.
Pets like phenomenology,
you know,
like I think it's very,
very difficult to claim that pain is,
is textual,
you know?
And we do know that you can,
you can manipulate the way an organism
feels pain quite extensively.
So,
for example,
if you whack the dog on the nose with a
newspaper,
every time it goes to eat,
it will starve to death.
You can teach it not to eat very
rapidly.
And so what you're doing is you're
teaching the dog that hunger is
punishing and then it transforms hunger
into anxiety and then it go heat.
So the reason I'm telling you that is
because even something as fundamental as
hunger,
which you might think about as a basic
phenomenon,
can be modulated by learning,
but there are limits to that.
There evident limits to that.
Now,
I think the problem with weaving a
narrative is that even if it's complex
and sophisticated,
and so you've convinced yourself,
that doesn't necessarily mean that the
actions and perceptions undertaken as a
consequence of that formulation are
going to be commensurate with the rest
of your personality.
It's a big risk,
you know?
So and I think it is the risk that
people run when they tell themselves or
act out at the false owed.
No,
because for Rogers,
you could also act out false hoods.
Right?
In fact,
the philosophers call that a
performative contradiction.
That's when you say one thing and do
another,
it's a form of lie,
but it's an embodied line.
Rogers was,
he was a very,
he was very cognizant of embodiment as
a,
as a central human feature.
So,
you know,
he was very concerned about the fact
that the representational structures had
to take into account the realities of
the underlying biology and those.
So those would be felt states in a
sense.
So I think the Rogerian answers,
you can't get away with it that easily.
What that'll do is it'll produce
contradictions as you move forward.
And those contradictions will,
will unsettle you either in a minor way
or in a deep way.
Now,
as far as I can tell by Rogers,
never really formalized a theory about
why something is deep and why something
was shallow in terms of it's
misrepresentation.
But we've already talked about that.
If you think about the hierarchical
structure that I showed you many times,
the idea there is that higher level of
the abstraction that you mess around
with,
the more of your personality you
pathologize.
And I,
I've been thinking this week too that,
that that hierarchy,
you know,
the one I showed you many times,
I believe I have any ways little eggs in
rows.
I think that's the structure of the
unconscious actually.
So,
and you miss about without at your peril
because you're programming your own
perceptions and your actions.
And so the Rogerian presupposition,
and this is why I'm talking about the
presuppositions that underlied is
thinking because the Rogerian approach
is based on a deep presupposition,
which is that honest integration
matters.
Now you could say,
well,
perhaps not.
It's like,
well,
that's been the question that people
have been debating since the beginning
of time.
But my experience as a therapist,
just so you know,
I've never seen anyone get away with
anything.
I think every time you do something that
you know isn't right,
you're going to get wall up for it.
Sooner or later.
Now you may be,
may have blinded yourself so badly
because of your ms apprehensions and
deceptions that you can't see the causal
connection between what you did and the
punishment.
In fact,
sometimes it takes years of
psychotherapeutic investigation to,
to lay out the causal narrative,
you know?
But why,
why would anybody ever think they can
bend the structure of reality and get
away with it?
You know?
To me it's like,
you know those plastic rulers,
it's like you can hold one of those in
front of your nose and bend it forward
and that's fine.
But as soon as you let go,
it's going to hit you in the face.
And so,
you know,
then you're going to curse,
faced fake because you got hit in the
face,
but you've been the down ruler.